if you do nothing else after
our evening together every day
for what remains to be now on election
day i want you to find somebody who
hasn't made a decision yet
say i ran into mike out at the airport
and and he ran to that stage every bit
as fast as he could
[Music]
and he told me that there's one question
i just got to ask you here's what you
just got to say
you got to say to somebody who do you
really think
is going to bring the american economy
all the way back
i mean just find an if somebody my
friend at worship at work could just say
no seriously
who do you really think is going to
ensure that
2021 we come all the way back and then
some a career politician who spent 47
years in washington
raising taxes growing government waiving
the white plan of economic surrender
when it comes to trade
or a proven job creator
who will keep cutting taxes rolling back
red tape
fighting for american jobs and american
workers
we need four more years of president
donald trump
in the white house
it's four more years for a great
american comeback north carolina
it is so it's about our national
security
and it's about our prosperity and our
future
but it's also about
law and order and public safety
and i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president who has stood
every day with the men and women
who serve in law enforcement all across
[Applause]
america
[Applause]
you know my i grew up in a small town in
southern indiana but my folks
grew up in chicago and we'd go up over
the holidays
visit my grandparents house and me and
my three brothers would be there in the
living room when my uncle had come
walking out
we're in that uniform of the chicago
police department
sidearm at his side we just look up in
awe
and to this day all my heroes wear
uniforms
the men and women who serve in law
enforcement all across this country are
some of the best people in america
and they deserve the respect of every
american
every day
[Music]
why don't we just show these law
enforcement officers who was with us
tonight just how much we appreciate
the job they do as they protect and
serve
great people
you know now joe biden says often that
he thinks america is systemically racist
joe biden and his running mate often say
that police in this country have a quote
implicit
bias against minorities
when joe was asked if he'd support
cutting funding law enforcement
he replied yes absolutely
and his running mate kamala harris she
recently played
praised the mayor of los angeles for
cutting 150 million dollars out of the
lapd
[Music]
but under president donald trump i'll
make you promise
we're not going to defund the police not
now
not ever we're going to back the blue
and we're going to back the blue for
four more years
but you all know north carolina the
president i know we don't have to choose
between supporting law enforcement
and supporting jobs and opportunity and
education prosperity for our
african-american neighbors and friends
and other minorities and families that
live in our cities
we've done both for the last three and a
half years
this president's actually provided
funding for the hiring of four thousand
police officers in the cops program
and when violence broke out in our major
cities this summer we launched operation
legend that's already seen to the arrest
of more than 3
000 violent offenders in cities across
the country
and at the same time under our economic
policies we had the lowest unemployment
ever recorded for
african americans the highest funding
ever
for historically black colleges and
universities
we passed criminal justice reform we
launched 8
000 opportunity zones attracting
billions of investment creating jobs
in our cities and we've fought to give
families and our cities the right to
choose
where their children go to school
regardless of their income
or area code
under president donald trump we're going
to have law and order
and prosperity and opportunity in every
city in this nation for every american
of every race and creed and color
so help us god
so it's about law and order the
foundation of which is the rule of law
and on that score in our first three and
a half years
i'm proud to report this president has
appointed more than 230 conservative
men and women to our federal courts
and they are all judges of integrity who
will uphold the god-given liberties
enshrined in our constitution
like the freedom of religion the freedom
of speech
and the second amendment right to keep
and bear arms
230 judges and that includes
justice neil gorsuch justice brett
kavanaugh
and justice amy coney barrett
is she great
and you know she's from indiana
just saying she's an amazing person
her personal story and her judicial
temperament and her
principles convictions have inspired
inspired people all over the country but
i'm particularly proud of the fact that
she's inspired young women across
america
which is altogether fitting because you
think the late justice ruth bader
ginsburg was a trailblazer for women
in the law and she's now followed by
a principal jurist another woman who
will serve with incredible distinction
and inspire
generations of women
in fact in the proud father category i'm
actually joined here tonight
by my youngest she is a recent
graduate of an ivy league law school
will be starting her career
inspired by just those type of women in
the law would you join me in welcoming
my daughter audrey pence
who's with us here tonight she is an
incredible young woman
i'm so proud of her
so we've made great progress in our
judiciary it's incredible
and none of it would have been possible
without the support of the people of
north carolina
electing a president who kept his word
and none of it would have been possible
without the strong
and principled and consistent support
on the judiciary committee and in the
senate
as a whole of senator tom tillis
would you join me in thanking senator
tom tillis for the way he has
stood for our constitution and stood
by the principled men and women we've
confirmed to our courts
great job
that's why right after you re-elect
president donald trump we
we need six more years of senator tom
tillis in the senate
and while you're at it while you're at
it
you should go ahead and vote for the
conservative republican
judges for the supreme court in north
carolina
am i right
you know speaking about our course
people of north carolina deserve to know
what senator tillis knows
he'll back me up on this after 150 years
with nine
judges on the supreme court leading
democrats in washington are now talking
about packing the court
it's true they're talking about adding
seats to the supreme court
so they can appoint liberal activist
judges who will
legislate their agenda from the bench
surrogates of the biden campaign
including some senators were on tv this
last weekend saying
absolutely open to it i just saw
aoc tweeted today three words expand the
court
now first joe biden and kamala harris
refused to answer the question of
whether they were going to pack the
court
i tried to get an answer out of kamala
harris during our debate
didn't have any luck then joe biden said
that he'd tell us after judge barrett
was confirmed
that's today but now
he goes into this weekend he says it's a
it's a live
ball
but he won't he won't tell us if he'll
pack the court
until months after the election
i mean come on man
the american people deserve a straight
answer joe
if you're running for the highest court
in the land
you're running for the highest office in
the land you've got to tell people
whether you'll respect the highest court
in the land
i mean you all get it they're not
answering the question because
we already know the answer right i mean
i was born in the morning but not
yesterday morning
and joe biden and kamal harris are going
to pack the supreme court
with left-wing activist judges if they
win this election
that's why north carolina we're not
going to let it
happen we're going to re-elect president
donald trump
and we're going to send senator tom
tillis back
to a republican majority in the united
states senate
for our constitution for an independent
judiciary
the stakes are that high
and you know because this is about this
is about
protecting the god-given liberties
enshrined
in our constitution and our founding
documents
and here in north carolina you all
deserve to know
i hope he's not on our runway
you all deserve to know when joe biden
was vice president
the american people witnessed a steady
assault on the freedom of religion
of charities and organizations across
this country
it's true they eroded the conscience
rights of doctors and nurses and
religious organizations they even hauled
a group of nuns
true story they hauled a group of nuns
into federal court to force them
to compromise their faith to live under
the standards of obamacare
and reflecting that same intolerance the
leading democrat on the judiciary
committee
two years ago when judge barrett was
going through her confirmation
said that she was concerned because amy
coney barrett's catholic
faith was so sincerely found
she did she she said she was concerned
because and i quote
the dogma lives loudly within you
and hollywood elites have been attacking
judge barrett ever since
but i've got a message for the democrats
in washington
and their friends in hollywood that
dogma lives loudly in me
that dogma lives loudly in you
and the right to live and work and
worship
according to the dictates of our faith
lives loudly in the constitution of the
united states
[Music]
under president trump we restored the
conscience rights of doctors and nurses
and religious organizations
president trump ended the assault on the
little sisters of the poor and the
supreme court of the united states
made it permanent and with four more
years we're going to continue
to stand for the religious freedom of
every american
of every faith so help us god
it really is about our liberties but
it's about one more thing
you know as your vice president
i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president
who stands without apology for the
sanctity of human life
[Applause]
and are calling for record increases in
funding of abortion
around the world and they want to
increase funding for the largest
abortion provider in america
under president donald trump in our
first few weeks in office we reinstated
the mexico city policy
preventing taxpayer dollars from being
used to promote abortion anywhere
in the world we stood by the hyde
amendment
preventing any taxpayer dollars from
being used to fund
abortion here at home and president
donald trump
signed into law the bill that allows
states to defund
planned parenthood
president donald trump is the most
pro-life president
in american history
[Music]
so in our first three years if you're
taking notes
we rebuilt our military we revived our
economy
we stood for law and order liberties and
life
and none of that would have been
possible without the strong and
consistent support
of north carolina's republican
delegation congress
that's true so
when we re-elect president donald trump
and send senator tom tillis back to the
united states senate
we need north carolina to send
congressman
david rouser to a new republican
majority on capitol hill and retire
nancy pelosi once and for all
[Applause]
out
i'm telling you
i was there 10 years ago the last time
we retired her and i tend to be around
when we retire nancy pelosi again
ma'am you know when you look at what we
were able to accomplish with a
republican house and a republican senate
in those first three years with this
president's leadership
only one way you can describe it
we made america great again
am i right yeah we did
it's incredible and then
the clone of irish struck from china
but i'm here to tell you even before
there was one
case of community spread anywhere in the
country
all the way back in january president
trump did what no american president had
ever done
he suspended all travel from china the
second largest economy in the world
president donald trump put the health of
america first
now joe biden said that was xenophobic
true
called it hysterical he said that
he said that closing off travel during a
global pandemic would make things worse
joe biden got it wrong
just like they did back in the swine flu
2009
when joe biden was vice president they
refused to close the border to mexico
and 60 million americans contracted the
swine flu
i mean the truth is that even his own
chief of staff said it was just
luck that the swine flu was not a
mass casualty event in the country
but i can tell you firsthand president
trump's decision to close down all
travel from china
saved untold american lives because it
bought us invaluable
time to stand up the greatest national
mobilization since world war ii
we reinvented testing
we started the manufacturing
distribution of hundreds of
billions of supplies of ppe
and equipment no american who ever
required a ventilator was ever denied a
ventilator
no american who ever required an icu bed
has ever been denied
an icu bed we've developed therapeutics
and medicines
that are saving lives and in a very
short period of time
we will have the first coronavirus
vaccine
in the world with tens of millions of
doses for the american people
it's coming in record time
and i promise you we're going to
continue to
move heaven and earth to make sure our
doctors and nurses
across the state and across this nation
have all the supplies they need
to give anyone the level of care that
we'd want a family member to have
we're going to continue saving lives
protecting the vulnerable
developing life-saving medicines until
that day
that we have a vaccine and put the
coronavirus in the past
but as we do that
joe biden's talking about shutting down
our economy
with president donald trump we are
opening up america again
we're doing it
it's amazing to think on the strong
foundation that we poured in those first
three years
and with the unprecedented historic
support
that senator tillis and congressman
rouser supported direct payments to
families direct payments to businesses
to keep people on the payroll
through paycheck protection in just the
last five months after losing 22 million
jobs
in this economy we've already seen
eleven and a half million people go back
to work
including 320 000 people
right here in north carolina
we're opening up america again and we
are opening up america's schools
but to keep opening up you know we need
president donald trump back in the white
house
and we also need you to send dan
forrest to the governor's office in the
great state of north carolina
so we've gone through a year of testing
very soon we're coming to a time for
choosing and i know that's why you came
out tonight
i mean the choice has never been clearer
the stakes have never been higher
i mean when you look at their agenda of
higher taxes
open borders socialized medicine and a
green new deal
it's obvious joe biden would be nothing
more than a trojan
horse for the radical left
now jill biden says that democracy is on
the ballot
well i think our economic recovery is
definitely on the ballot
i think law and order are on the ballot
but i also think there's things much
more foundational to who we are
as americans you know in this election i
think it's
it's not going to be so much whether
america ends up more republican or more
democrat
more liberal or more conservative more
red or more blue
i think the choice in this election is
whether america remains america
whether we're gonna let joe biden and
the democratic party
and the radical left take us somewhere
that america's never been before
of less freedom
more government socialism and american
decline
or whether we're going to reaffirm our
commitment to all the things that have
always made america great
faith and family and freedom
and free enterprise and a boundless
american future
the choice is just that clear the stakes
are just that high
so men and women for our freedom
for everything that's always made
america
exceptional and great
for ourselves for our children and our
children's children
we need to decide right here and right
now
that jill biden will never be president
of the united states we're going to
re-elect
president donald trump for four more
years
you know i've served alongside this
president over the last four years
we've either been together every day or
spoken every day
some people think we're a little bit
different
but actually we've become very close
friends i've seen him when the bright
lights are off
and the cameras are off and i can tell
you
straight up
that against unrelenting resistance
obstruction and opposition by the
democrats in washington
against unrelenting and unfair attacks
from their allies in the national media
there has never been a day
in the last three and a half years when
this president hasn't gotten
up and fought to keep the promises that
he made
to the people of north carolina now it's
our turn to fight for him
it's on north carolina
we need to bring it
we need you to stay in the fight every
day until the polls close come november
3rd
and deliver a great victory so i'm going
to ask you do a couple things and then i
got a plane to catch
first and foremost i checked senator
tillis told me
early voting has already started
so first and foremost
i need you to vote north carolina vote
to re-elect president donald trump and
this entire republican team
and karen and i we voted early in
indianapolis last friday the president
cast his vote down in florida
i voted for four more years of president
donald trump in the white house
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so did he
anyway well you need to get it done
because there's work to do
in between i'm going to get to that in a
second but just go get get your vote
done if you don't know how
just tomorrow go down to the wilma w
daniels art gallery at cfcc
200 hanover street it's just outside the
airport
they're open 8 o'clock to 7 30 weekdays
and remember friends don't let friends
vote alone
bring a family member bring a neighbor
bring a co-worker
and vote for four more years of
president donald trump
in the white house
secondly after you vote
early with a friend
i need you to reach out to
neighbors and co-workers that worship
and at work
just talk to them about everything that
we talked about tonight
tell them why you came out tonight why
you feel so passionately about this
president tell them about promises made
and promises kept
tell them about the choice we face in
this election
you know i'll never forget in the last
election you know
about this time
there were all different types of polls
out there some that had us losing by a
lot and some that had us losing by
little
right remember
it might sound a little familiar
but i gotta tell you from my heart i
never doubted
that this country was going to say yes
to the vision and the leadership of
president donald trump
because i was traveling around the
country in that campaign and i was
seeing faces just like i'm seeing
tonight
i was seeing people that knew we knew we
could
be stronger we could strengthen the
foundations of everything that's always
made this country great
you know the president uh he and i run
60 minutes the other night it was
it was 60 minutes
but i don't know if you heard it he was
asked he was asked by the
interviewer he said can you describe can
you describe your supporters
and without hesitation he said yes
they're people who love our country
what am i great it's true
and so take your love of country reach
out to your neighbors and friends
every day between now and when the polls
close
and tell them we need four more years of
president donald trump
in the white house will you do it
there's nothing more powerful than
hearing from somebody
you know and trust about an issue that
you
believe is important to their family to
the community the state and the nation
so let your voice be heard and finally
after you vote with a friend
early